Well, what he actually said was
uh, that Taco Bell burritos don't count as
real burritos?
Which is not true at all.
Right?
Hm?
Yeah, burritos suck balls bro.
Anna?
Hey, what did I say about no stupid cellphone at the table?
*gasps* Don't call him stupid!  He can hear you.
Don't you see the little ears?
Okay, since when is your phone a guy?
Sometimes I feel like you're in love with your cellphone more than me.
Not more.  Just different.
This is getting out of hand.
Anna?
Hey!  Anna.
Who's under the sheets?
No one, I'm just playing with my cellphone.
Aw, isn't he so cute when he naps?
You know it would be great if
you start referring to it as a female
or at least something gender neutral.
I'm sorry, Celly identifies as a man.
Look, Anna, I know that you love the movie "Her."
This is too much, okay?
Okay.  We'll go watch Netflix.
Okay.
Cool.
Anna.  What the Hell is this?
I'm ready to watch Netflix.
I thought we were going to watch Netflix.
Not you me and your phone.
What's wrong with Celly being here?
I just--
You're always so distracted with the phone.
I can't handle this anymore.
Okay?  What's so much better about him?
He has all the answers.
Can I ask you how many spiders crawl into
a person's mouth in their lifetime?
You don't know that.
I can take photos,
I can look at my photos,
I can share my photos,
I can figure out what date it is!
This is better than you because it's a machine.
I can't take it anymore.
It's either him or me.
You know you have a phone too, right?
Oh.
[Laughing]
What's so funny?
Nothing.
Just paying my gas bill.
Hey guys, I hope you enjoyed that sketch.
Clearly, it comes from my own addiction
to my phone.
And I just had to talk about it so
thanks Brad for being in it with me.
But before I go, I did want to mention,
Have you seen "Hey USA" Season 2?  The trailer?
Doesn't it look adorable?
Jenna Marbles and Mamrie Hart
in like those giant overalls like in that lake is just--I can't even.
So, "Hey USA", if you don't know
is a travel show by the people, for the people
and this season, season 2
Mamrie Hart is going to take YouTubers that you picked
and go all over America, wherever Grace Helbig tells them to.
So it's got some of my favorites!  Like Mr. Flooa
Kingsley, and of course Jenna Marbles
and Tyler Oakley, and Colleen, and so many more!
So if you want to check it out you can
subscribe to their Youtube Channel here.
Or you can follow them on Twitter at "Hey USA."
It's going to be adorable.
It's going to be fun, it's going to be America.
I'm Anna Akana.  You stay awesome.